we're from another country getting used
to the way that the business are
structured and very different from back
home and home for you is Costa Rica and
your first deal was in Costa Rica our
very first rental sa having that good
relationship with the landlord ended up
getting us like five of them of the 13
that we have wow I didn't know that I
knew the help to buy was a scam I didn't
know it was that much of a communistic
scam that says how much is your property
business making a year 330 000. you know
that's more than quarter of a million
pounds it sounds better when you say
that yeah but actually with property
there's so many different strategies you
just gotta figure them out find out
what's best for you I've noticed the
more value you give to others the more
money to get back you can see all the
free videos that you like on YouTube but
you will never learn what you need to
learn until you actually pay for proper
education
firstly congrats on your huge success oh
thank you thank you did you expect that
you would be turning over so much money
when you first got started in this
business no I don't think so and you got
off to a proper Rocky start yeah yeah it
was it was rough at the beginning uh I
think we were very excited about it uh
so we did try hard but I think we just
needed to develop the skills so it just
meant that at the beginning we needed to
just try try and try and try until we
get getting better and also getting used
to like uh we're from another country so
like getting used to like everything
here like the culture the the way that
the business are structured and things
like that is very different from back
home right so getting used to that as
well and home for you is Costa Rica
Costa Rica and your first deal was in
Costa Rica yeah it was yeah the
strategies that we teach are not just UK
they are worldwide yeah that's true
that's completely true yeah so talk to
me about the first deal then that you
did in Costa Rica uh so it's a
commercial shop uh it's near the beach
so basically we found a place that we
felt was undervalued so we negotiated
with the seller to buy it cheaper and
then we use a leverage to use uh only
that and basically the rent is paid
completely so basically no money down
deal at the end and we got the idea
after watching some videos and at the
end even though the profit is not that
high because the rent is not that high
uh it has been completely like infinite
return yeah because we didn't use any of
our money so exactly and is it passive
as well very positive I think from
everything that we have that's the most
possible yeah the most thing that we had
to do was change the aircon one time
that's okay yeah yeah wow and that what
is it then who are you tenants a
Colombian guy that sells and repairs
cell phones so it's just like a little
shop yeah it's been there since the
beginning so yeah nice couple of years
no money down deal so who financed that
was that the bank an individual is it a
private yes bank and some loan but yeah
so you've got a mortgage on it yeah and
then you've got like what a personal
loan but you would make a profit
absolutely exactly because it wasn't a
much difference so yeah basically uh
there and we we know that both were
going to be paid completely with with
the rent so yeah nice and then you
started doing stuff in the UK yeah yes
exactly because we're here most of the
time uh so we started well first we went
for for one of your one pound course
because we've been following you for a
while and we've always wanted to just go
to the live course but we thought we had
to wait until we pay the help to buy
which is a funny story we bought our
house using that it'll help to buy
equity loan uh but then we realized we
were gonna buy some by to Let's we
realized we couldn't buy a second
property when you have the help to buy
no you have to pay first okay yeah oh I
knew the help to buy was a scam yeah I
didn't know it was that much of a of a
communistic scam that says if you're
with us you can't even oh no the
property yeah their idea is that if you
have money to buy a second property you
should pay them first yeah so you have
to pay first the government to help to
buy equity loan before buying a second
it's a scam yeah so it is kind of a
Scarface
yeah you know more than anyone yeah
correct me from one because you've done
it I've never done it but for what my
research yeah help to buy they don't
gift you the money they loan you the
money yeah so that's the first thing
secondly you have to live in the house
yes so if you live in the house it's not
an asset yeah because you're not making
any cash flow your property in Costa
Rica is an asset who's giving you cash
flow yeah the third thing is it only
applies generally to new build houses
which means that we all know that when
you buy a new build house it's inflated
do you buy it and it usually drops which
means you're a negative equity and then
the fourth reason I didn't even know is
that you can't be a problem
yeah and probably trapped you into this
yeah work hard be in a job forever yeah
exactly yeah yeah actually we delayed
going to your course because of it but
at the end we lost time time because if
we knew that we could like if we knew
all the strategies that you teach we
could have gone sooner and just do
rentals that would be fine yes for
example so we paid a price of not going
before yeah the knowledge Gap yeah we
paid a price for that because
interesting yeah because we waited I
waited like I don't know like a year
with okay now we can refinance and all
that and then okay let's go to the
course and then go to the first course
and it's like we could have been here a
year ago yeah and that's another thing
is interesting a lot of people that are
like in maybe they have uh bad credit
and they think oh I need to get this
story before or maybe they are Muslim
and they think I can't I can't use debts
but actually with property there's so
many strategies there's deal sourcing
there's rent to rent service
accommodation planning game developments
there's just commercial there's so many
different strategies you just gotta
figure them out find out what's best for
you exactly how much is your property
business making now uh a year 330 000.
fist bump 330 you know that's more than
quarter of a million pounds it sounds
better when you say it like that yeah
turnover yes
you should do more this year because you
know that's taking it out hey
we'll do more though I know it's a bit
you know
what do you expect to do this year so
based on the properties we have right
now should be more like for 20 for 40
something we need to get that to half a
million match that'll be very exciting
yeah that's crazy and how many
properties is that so that comes from 13
run to Estates yeah we have and also we
have our property staging business and
yeah maybe some deal selling but yeah
basically most of it comes from the
rental essays and you're An Architect by
background yeah background so staging
properties is easy for you yes it's like
child Supply but it's not easy you know
so no no definitely that's no like it's
more about the time you need to do it
quick it's faster you need to be cost
effective it's not like just pay
whatever you you want for them like yeah
you need to think about return of every
item so I remember when I was about 17
years old 18 years old that sort of age
and I had got a property and I got it
really set up the builders said that
they'll be completely finished by the
end of May so I thought cool I'll
advertise it ready from the first of
June obviously Builders always go over
and they're a pain I had to really chase
them and they had about three days to
furnish it and I went to Ikea and I got
all the stuff and then I'm like holy
moly I need a flat back
at 4 00 a.m for a week every night like
working at 6
our first like couple of properties that
we staged we do it we did it like that
like we got the flat pack noise and we
thought it's not worth it the money that
we're getting for it like no no no time
so now yeah so now yeah we have
everything more systemized we have
context in the area right now it's only
Northeast that they supplier the
furniture and they do all the assembly
and everything right and that's so much
easier and use of what oversee it yeah
they do the the actual flat packing side
of things or whatever it is and then you
make it look really pretty yeah who are
you selling that to how are you finding
these people who are they mostly
investors that are coming to the north
to a refurb hmos so most of them I think
all of them have been hmos most of them
are coming through our partner Luis he
helped us out in in bringing the
investors in and then we just sell them
like the station package nice so that's
your only involvement with these
investors just to Stage their property
is yeah basically cool yeah yeah cool
and what percentage of your turnover
would you say is the furniture and
dressing side of it well they'll be on
top of that 330 so oh on top yes we can
definitely get to half a million then
I'll bet that's not even included no
this is a new way so yeah I think we've
done like four okay yeah but yeah
turnover I think uh on that one was like
11. last month was eleven thousand sure
do you guys just have the Midas touch
when it comes to money I'll watch the
Arnold Schwarzenegger documentary
recently and it was like
everything he does just turns to Gold
honestly like he became a Mr Olympian
then he got to Hollywood and became a
famous actor and then he said he just
slipped out he's like oh before I got
into Hollywood I just got a property
mentor and did a few property deals and
became a millionaire what and it's the
same way when you just slip out oh yeah
we did 11 Grand last month on an extra
bit we didn't even include how are you
so successful what's the key to your
success in property we are in a rush to
get to a place and that place is having
the freedom not only in the passive
income but also in time to be able to go
as much as we can to our Costa Rican
family every now and then so that's like
our goal we want to be able to go there
three months see our family come back
and we don't have to worry about a job
also we're always trying to see how to
systemize it how to make it passive so
it doesn't depend on us even if it means
making a little bit less profit but if
we do
completely hands off that's totally
worth it yeah also I think I've learned
uh how important is just to help people
people pay you for helping them it's
just instead of like it's hard but to
start thinking about you and just I've
noticed that you just help people and
it's just a way of generating more money
towards you but you just focus on that
it's a hard mind game because you're
worried about yourself but I've noticed
the more value you give to others the
more money you get back yeah but of
course is finding that they need
somebody to do and how ways to do it and
that's part of what we've learned but
you know that it's just the process and
I feel the more we feel we help someone
I feel the more we're getting back and
we'll find like more places and more
ways we can do it of course from you
learn about systemizing so it doesn't
take so much of our time so you wouldn't
be able to do staging if we didn't know
how to systemize the rent to rent and
vice versa so I think also we have more
time and More Time Each time to do other
things so that also I think helps if
nobody will be trapped in just one thing
oh man actually reading a book at the
moment called working backwards and it's
about Amazon so it's a lot of it's about
Jeff Bezos and it's about how Amazon win
their business and it's it's working
backwards it starts with what do
customers want you know Sam was just
Steve Jobs obviously Steve Jobs quite a
lot and it's like he'd be like right
this is what the customers want this is
how they went to look this is how they
want to feel yeah so it starts with how
can I give people what they want I love
what you said about helping people yeah
and when you when you give enough people
what they want then in return you get
what you want yeah you know and as
Albert Einstein said Albert Einstein
said don't try and be successful try and
be valuable yes and in the same way when
you're doing your property business your
rent to rent it's like what do our
guests want yeah how do they want this
play stage do they want a desk yeah
what's the demographic what do they want
yeah what are the investors want what
are they looking for and when you're
thinking about everything it's actually
it's a very Noble thing to get rich yeah
because in getting rich you're basically
giving lots of people what they want
yeah when you're selfless you get rich
actually that's something I've learned
through you and and you know the the
academy like you've said it several
times it takes a while for you to
realize but then you're like I don't
have money because I'm not helping
enough people yeah and then in the rent
to essays like rsas when they were not
doing that great it's like we improve
improve improve we're helping them now
they're doing better so we're doing
better so it's just that it's just hard
to give when you don't have yeah because
it's just like delayed and and in that
sense also with the landlord side of
things with the rent to rent for example
we've noticed that like the the good
relationship that you have with the
landlords ah they just give you more
property so for example we have an
example of our very first rent to sa at
the end having that good relationship
with the landlord ended up like getting
us like five of them of the 13 that we
have wow they're not all from him but he
refers I think it was his niece that had
another property and then they also had
like a friend that had a property nearby
he refers to us right so keeping like
giving a good service yeah
alerts as well yeah is very important
absolutely and the thing is as well we
rent to rent a lot of people will watch
my YouTube videos and they'll see how
profitable rent to rent can be they'll
see you making over a quarter of a
million pounds in rent to rent and then
I think I want a rent to rent how do I
get a landlord to give me a rent to rent
how do I convince and persuade a
landlord wrong mentality yeah the
question is how can I make my offer so
irresistibly attractive to the landlords
and to the agents that they want to give
me their property yes yeah what's in it
for them backwards yes and that's
something we learn and actually people
ask us do you know any recommendations
is just listen to the lender like just
go and it's not about going talking it's
about going listening yeah and they'll
tell you what they need they'll tell you
they're just tired of just people coming
in I don't know they just ruined my my
kitchen have to replace it so okay
that's what they need that's where I can
help them with okay
yeah be sure everything's gonna be clean
be nice I love that and that's why
there's no one magic script yeah yeah
it's about listening asking questions
yeah and then learning to listen to what
they want yeah and then putting together
an offer or proposal that is good for
them yeah exactly they're satisfying
their needs we try not to talk at the
beginning and then just ask questions
questions and after they just told us
everything they need that's when we
start talking because okay now you know
we know what you need so now let's let's
talk about how we solve it interesting
as well is that we talk about the modest
touch and it appears someone could watch
this and just think this couple have
just got it all figured out everything
they touch is successful and prosperous
but it hasn't always been that way no no
taught us about the beginning well first
we came to the academy and we thought
that we wanted to do BRS because
buildings are architect he has always
loved development my parents have built
Apartments back in Costa Rica so I
always like ah development or BR like
something that we fancy but then we
realized that we what we really needed
was a cash flow and then when we decided
went to sa it was really hard it took us
like two full months of really really
trying calling calling calling don't
going doing viewings and getting a lot
of rejections 100 plus rejections
probably we had like a spreadsheet
everything read every time they say no
so it was very hard time yeah we had a
spreadsheet where like you change like
if it's which stage of the lead was it
yeah and it wouldn't read when they
rejected us they were working full time
at the time so it had to be weekends or
late at night and were you living in the
UK at this point yes so you were doing
Architects and marketing at the time uh
after uh graduating from architecture I
started a marketing company so I was
working on there like but as an employee
basically basically I just created my
own job I was thinking yeah yeah and
that's interesting point as well talking
about systemization yeah a lot of people
think they have their own business they
actually have their own job yeah and
they get paid less often than you were
but a lot of self-employed people or
business owners get paid less than the
minimum wage when you take all of their
costs off and their actual
and they're working like slaves yeah
yeah and then after well after the a lot
of no's and the rejections yes uh we
finally got our first one it was
performing a bit badly and then we went
to a mastermind on a Monday and then we
heard some some stories I think it was
Priscilla and her husband yeah yeah yeah
they joined really similar to us in time
wise and they had like one when we met
and by that time they were they were
almost like on 10 grand a month or
something like that yes they were doing
really well and we were just with one
and and it was not he was losing money
like when we know we have to blame
ourselves for the success no one else so
we're like what are we doing wrong and
we're really really down after that call
sometimes sometimes The Mastermind you
have sometimes they just interested yeah
but you need that yeah why do you need
that I think you need that like just to
get your together
because I've had I have had some people
say that to me they've said live I
demotivates me because I see everybody
else succeeding because there's a lot of
people succeeding pretty big yeah and it
makes me feel bad it reminds me of when
I was training for my boxing fight and
sometimes I'd go I'd go sparring and
everyone would be kicking my ass
[Music]
but you have to go through that because
it raises the standard the reason you
felt crappy about yourself was because
you could see Priscilla and other people
winning and you're you're we need to be
there and it answers you and it's like
ah but that actually is what gives you
the fire to get better yeah because
there's no excuses like that's what
helps is like
you could be there because you know you
got access to the same knowledge who's
then to blame if you have access to the
same knowledge is us like we need to get
better so what have you learned from
that what do you do differently now as a
was it was it your fault was it was it
laziness or was it that you just it's
probably not lazy that's because you
made 100 calls what was it okay okay so
the problem was that at the beginning we
thought we need to hire a property
manager so we had this company he was
managing it but it's not the same as
when you manage it yeah yeah I think we
took more control yes it like okay we we
need to make it work it's not gonna
depend on something so you're just
completely outsourced the management of
it and just assumed that they'd do a
great job yes but they don't give a
monkeys because it's not their business
exactly and they'll just get their 15 20
so it's not the same so we just took
full control of the property and it's
not that hard people like it is hard but
one it's fine you should be fine with
one you can do it in your extra time
because we were working full time so
since the beginning we always try to
have everything very systemized we
started researching pricing wise in the
area what to change yeah and then like
for example we learn about price lab
like more Dynamic pricing something we
didn't have also open rain we actually
got like a six months uh relocator yeah
just by being more proactive on it and
then that just basically that means that
was safe for six months let's go for the
next one one of the things I often say
and I'm sure you've probably heard me
say many times is that in business and
in life you always have problems and to
begin with it might be like oh I've got
the help to buy that's stopping me yeah
then it's I want to join the academy oh
but it's a big investment then it's I'm
on the academy I've got access to all
the mentoring training but I'm
struggling to get my first deal yeah
yeah then it's like my first deal but
I'm struggling to rent it out okay now
I've got multiple deals what's your
biggest problem today it's killing
without overwhelming ourselves and that
that's like it's always like a I think
you you get at a point where like you're
systemized go back improve and then
we're thinking now how do we keep
growing here well also don't miss on our
family like it's been a lot we've been
here like eight years so I think it's a
long time away and we want to start
going back so how can we keep growing
scaling so I guess it's a case of
continuing to grow in the sky at the at
the speed and the volume you have been
doing but also almost systemizing in the
scaling scalability exactly yeah exactly
well also I remember at The Accelerated
coaching performance program where we
spent a couple of days together maybe a
few months ago now and I said to you
about diversifying as well ah yes yes
that's the other challenge I agree yeah
how are you doing that because I said to
you you're making a load of money most
of it is coming from service
accommodation yes the rules might change
yeah you never know you know or or the
market might change yes so how are you
ensuring you've got your commercial
property which is awesome but it's not
giving you a load of cash flow but it's
great yeah but how are you diversifying
your portfolio to ensure that the table
stands on multiple legs well I think the
next project is the development that we
are planning in Costa Rica right now
have you got one lined up yes we're like
in process of making the floor plans and
going through planning I'd love to come
and see it yeah oh yeah yeah I'd love to
come see it yeah once it starts once
it's once you've got that let me know
I'll come out and let's do a video there
yeah
so what is this project that you've
you're in the process of securing right
now there's two plots let's say of land
where we are negotiating it with that
well we already negotiated with the
landlady and she would put in the land
and we will just get the finance to
build a four apartments two in each of
the plots one above the other so so just
to understand so it's a piece of land
yeah the lady will almost joint venture
with you by giving you the land for free
but you will then build four Apartments
yeah and then you will then give her a
percentage of the profit she will keep
what a great concept yeah yeah amazing
yeah what are the numbers each uh land
is like 60 000 and then uh construction
foreign
[Music]
100 but maybe maybe less okay and how
much will you make on that deal so when
I saw your refinance yeah
okay so you've got about 100 Grand in
yourself the rest you'll get from the
bank the land is going to be good so
you're putting about 100 000 pounds cash
in but then at the end you'll pull it
out and then you'll be left with some
apartment yeah it could be even unless I
think it might be like 60 000 we have to
win 75. that should be honest yeah and
is it close to the beach no that one's
in the capital San Jose yeah and the
good thing about that as well is it's
totally Diversified because it's a
different strategy and it's in a
different country yeah yeah it means if
england goes to kaput
you've got Costa Rica
yeah it's really nice
so start building in bolts a little bit
Yeah Yeah like around like having in
both countries what was the biggest
moment for you where you were like oh my
gosh this is actually working probably
when we would have thought like wow this
all the effort is paying off yeah was
last month because we got like 20 grand
profit from the from the renters after
because first it was reinvesting
reinvesting and then right we thought
okay let's focus on improving them and
then I feel like last month all
everything just paid off and it's like
okay all the work you've been doing yeah
it's actually paying you know that's not
life-changing man yeah yeah yeah and
also it's been very interesting because
we've been reinvesting a lot of the
profits that means that between all of
us like the four Partners in the rent to
rent at the beginning we only had two
like the only cash that we had to put in
it was like five a thousand pounds each
that's all that's how much that's how
much have we been in for the rentals
that's it for the 13. wow
what a story actually we invested more
in knowledge than yeah
which is awesome because if we hadn't I
think we would have been
I love the idea of building a
development business in Costa Rica and
really Diversified like crazy for you I
think the biggest thing now is training
a team getting getting some staff in the
UK like maybe an MD or something in the
UK and that'd be huge yeah
um wow inspiring guys inspiring what's
been the biggest lesson then over the
over the last kind of a year or so it
educate yourself even though you think
you're not ready for it just go pay for
courses join the academy if you have to
you can see all the free videos that you
like on YouTube but you will never learn
what you need to learn until you
actually pay for proper education and
that's no shade on YouTube or anything
it's like no I've said this before it's
like if you want to learn any industry
if you want to learn to be a pilot you
don't learn from YouTube YouTube will
give you an overview understanding I'm
trying to learn paragliding at the
moment I love paragliding and I watched
a few YouTube videos you gave me an idea
I'll get the basics but you actually
need to go and do it by any instructions
yeah otherwise you'll die and in
property you'll die financially you know
so yeah it makes sense yeah like
watching your videos this way we got
like the commercial shop and we got like
no money down yeah but thanks for the
Academy is that we got the success that
we have right now so it's just it just
gets exponential it's just I remember uh
one of our first courses you go thinking
everything is black and white on
property and I came out and uh Chris uh
I told him like everything is like great
colors and he's like it's color man so I
like it just meant for me that there's
so many things so many ways you can be
so creative yeah and that's what I think
opened my mind uh by going like to the
courses and learning from you and Chris
and everyone from the academy it's just
that opens your mind it's just that's
what's so exciting it's like now you can
do whatever you want you just mix this
with that like list option with essays
with brrs yeah and it's just so many
options that you couldn't see before and
I think that was probably one of the
biggest lessons well guys thank you for
coming on the show have yourself a
wonderful afternoon and I'm here anytime
man let me know how you get on with that
customer deal
and uh thanks for coming on once again
inspiring the YouTube fans no thank you
so much for having us yeah
[Music]
thank you